I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello. Hi there. of VFF Stories or the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi there. We are excited. Yeah, if you read the episode description for today's episode, you're in the right place. Yes. So here's the thing, we have a very special guest today. Yeah, it is skateboarding legend, Tony Hawk.
I mean, I don't think you can even mention skateboarding without immediately thinking of Tony Hawk. He's the most famous skateboarder, of course. Yes. Yeah. I mean, he started skating professionally when he was just 14. He is a pioneer of the sport. He helped popularize and evolve the sport of skateboarding for like over 40 years.
And he's still skateboarding today. Yes. Yeah, he is also a successful entrepreneur in the skateboarding industry. He created Birdhouse Skateboards, Hawk Clothing, and his hugely successful video game, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater. And he is the founder of the non-profit Skate Park Project. That is his philanthropic mission
to help underserved communities create safe and inclusive public skate parks for all youth. Which I love it. I mean, I talked to Tony about it because I spent a lot of my high school years at skate parks because my first boyfriend was a skateboarder. How about that, you guys? Did you know Jenna would hang out at skate parks?
I found that out when we started talking about having Tony Hawk on. Yeah. I did not know that about you. It's so weird. And getting to talk to him and all of it, it brought up so many memories from my youth. After we did the interview with him, I took a picture with him,
and I just sent it to my friend. Wait, can I tell everyone what you said? You said, Tony, can I take a picture with you for I just sent it to my... Wait, can I tell everyone what you said? You said, Tony, can I take a picture with you for my boyfriend from high school? Yeah, I just want to send it to him with no explanation. So I actually don't have his contact information, but I sent it to the three girls from high school. I'm going to shout them out, Kim, Sarah, and Ellen.
The four of us would hang out at the skate park with our skateboarding boyfriends. And so I sent it to them. What did they say? And my friend Ellen wrote back, this is like a photo of my high school years in a nutshell. And my friend Sarah said, what is happening? Exactly. You all might be thinking what is happening? So we should probably share how this interview came about. When you think Tony Hawk, you probably don't think Office Ladies. About a year ago, we got word that Tony Hawk wanted to be a guest on Office Ladies
and we were like, what, what, what? We couldn't believe it. He's an icon. He's one of the greats. Tony Hawk. It turns He's one of the greats. He's Tony Hawk. He's Tony Hawk. It turns out he's a huge Office fan. We couldn't even believe that Office Ladies was on his radar. Yeah. But here was the thing, you know, we were in that last stretch of the Office rewatch. We were building up to the finale. I was finishing up chemotherapy.
So it took us a few months of trying to schedule Tony. We've been going back and forth and back and forth. And finally, it has all come together and he joined us in studio in person. In person, all six foot three of him was in our studio. He's so tall. I wasn't prepared for how tall. I had heard he's tall, but you know, I'm so short. So when he walked in, I was like,
oh my God, you're Tony Hawk. Oh my God, you're so tall. So yeah, I mean, it was such a delight to have him in the studio. We talk about the office. We talk about his career as a skateboarder, all the things he's learned along the way. He's such an interesting person
and he's had to pivot so many times in his life and Jenna and I could really relate to that. Yeah, I found it very inspirational. And you should all know that the newest version of his video game, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 & 4 is out July 11th. Of this year? Yes, you can pre-order it now on Xbox Series XS,
Xbox One, PlayStation 4 & 5, Steam, Battle.net, Microsoft PC Store, and Nintendo Switch. Lady, my friend Buffy, who's a skateboarder, said a bunch of her friends are skaters that are featured in the game. And they had so much fun being a part of it and that it's gonna be really, really awesome. I mean, it looks so cool. I watched a little video of a behind the scenes
Xbox One, PlayStation 4 & 5, Steam, Battle.net, Microsoft PC Store, and Nintendo Switch. Lady, my friend Buffy, who's a skateboarder, said a bunch of her friends are skaters that are featured in the game. And they had so much fun being a part of it and that it's gonna be really, really awesome. I mean, I looks so cool. I watched a little video of a behind the scenes
of making it. And, you know, they put Tony in one of those suits with the little, I don't know, what are they? They're like little camera balls like all over them. Yeah, like how they do Avatar. Yeah. Where they put the little balls on people. I wanna do that just once.
Oh, you wanna be a ball person? I wanna have the little camera balls, but I don't know what my expertise would be. Cause it's always something sort of fantastical or sports or. Yeah. I know. Well, we need to get you in like a fantasy movie, just right. Please, Lord, from her mouth to your ears.
Camera balls on Angela. Camera balls on me, please. In a fantasy film, please. Putting it out there. Putting it out there. Well, my sons know about this game. They're very excited about the new version coming out. And Tony shared with us a little bit about just the music
that's part of it. Yeah, it has an amazing soundtrack and it features a variety of new skate parks. They added a water park. So cool. By the way, if you haven't seen the HBO documentary until the wheels come off about Tony Hawk, it is incredible.
Incredible. It is all about his life and career. It was made by the amazing Sam Jones. It features tons of interviews from different skateboarders, from members of the Bones Brigade, which is the skateboarding group he skated with when he was younger. It's gonna be a great two hours of your life.
Highly recommend. So great. Josh had seen it a while back and he was like, before we even knew Tony was gonna be on, he was like, Ang, this is a great documentary. You've gotta watch it. And there's also just so much footage of Tony growing up.
You really realize how much skateboarding, how much of his life it spans since he was nine years old. I also really loved how the documentary got into his relationship with his father and the way that his father was so supportive of his skateboarding. It was something that he had that not a lot of skateboarding kids have.
And it was really cool. So you guys, we were really nervous to interview Tony because like we said, he is one of the greatest athletes of all time. He is a total legend, but he was so wonderful and we had such a nice time talking to him. We're so excited to share this interview with you. I mean, I still can't believe it really happened.
I can either. But let's take a break and when we come back, it's our interview with Tony Hawk. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you know that workplace stress is now one of the top causes of declining mental health with 61% of the global workforce experiencing higher than normal levels of stress? I did not know that. Well, we can't just say goodbye to these things, you know?
We can't just say goodbye to work, but you can start a focus on wellness. Yes, and that focus on wellness can come in many forms. It can be for me taking a walk. You could reach out to a therapist on BetterHelp. With over 35,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform. They've served over 5 million people globally. It's convenient too. You can join a session with a therapist at the click of a button. As the largest online therapy provider in the world,
BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Unwind from work with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash Office Ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-l-p, dot com slash office ladies. Hey, I'm Ben Stiller. And I'm Adam Scott.
And we host a podcast called the Severance Podcast, where we used to break down every episode of the TV show Severance. Severance isn't back just yet, but the podcast is. Each week we'll discuss the movies, TV shows, and ideas that influence the making of Severance. We're going to talk to the incredible artists who inspire us to do what we do. The Severance podcast returns Thursday, June 26. Follow and listen everywhere you get your podcasts. Hello! Hi! Tony Hawk! I'm here. In the studio at Office Ladies. Can't believe it. Well, I can't either.
I mean, I'm excited. I can't believe it because it was on my calendar for a while. And then I also rescheduled. I apologize. No, we are so excited. Thank you. Jenna and I are both just trying to play it cool because we're really big fans. I mean, you're kind of a bigger than life person for us.
And so this is really amazing. Oh, I appreciate it. You guys are legends and part of the world. I mean, you're kind of a bigger than life person for us. And so this is really amazing. Oh, I appreciate it. You guys are legends and part of a TV legacy that I don't think will ever be topped. Truly. It's unreal. I mean, we're like, I'm speechless. To have those words come out of your mouth is just like so crazy.
Oh, honestly, I mean, I'll jump right into it, but I watched it obviously from day one. And then when my daughter got to be the age where she appreciated it, COVID hit, and we just went all the way through from the very beginning to the end. And it was a really special time to share with my daughter. Yeah.
Because it was, you know, COVID, school, stuff in your room, everything. And that was something that we did every day. It was really cool. So thank you. Because it was, you know, COVID, school, stuff in your room, everything. And that was something that we did every day. It was really cool. So thank you. So you watched it when it was originally on, but then you recently did the whole binge. Well, is that recent now?
2020? Recent-ish? Right. Don't, let's, I don't know about my retainment of knowledge, but yeah, it was pretty recent. I mean, we heard you were a super fan of The Office. There is a Reddit thread called Tony Hawk as a fan of The Office. I think you- Really?
Yes. Yes. I guess you said in an interview one time, oh, how the turntable turns or something. Oh, yes. And everyone like jumped on that. Yes. It started a thread. Oh, how the turntables.
Yes, exactly. That's it. You didn't even know the quote. I did, I got it wrong. I always get it wrong. Well, I have an office related question for you. If you could only watch one episode for the rest of your life.
I knew this was coming. What would you pick? Okay, I was gonna go for the low hanging fruit of Booze Cruise. That's a very good choice. Yes, and then my wife and I recently watched Casino Night. Oh, that's a good one. So good.
That was it. That was my choice. Oh no, no. I take it back. I'm sorry. We watched Casino Night and then we realized, dinner party. Dinner party is the best. You're naming three, like, of the top episodes.
That was it. That was my choice. Oh no, no. I take it back. I's sorry. We watched Casino Night and then we realized, dinner party. Dinner party is the best. You're naming three, like, of the top episodes.
Okay, but dinner Party was the absurdity and the idea that you get to see them and their element and their living space, that was the best. Yeah. That was one of the most fun episodes that Jenna and I did. And I mean, we loved the show.
We loved the conference room scenes and party planning committee and just all of it. Oh no, with their house. But Dinner Party, walking into Michael and Jan's condo, you can't unsee that. That lives with their house. But dinner party, like walking into Michael and Jan's condo, like you can't unsee that. Yes. That lives with you forever. Yeah. What was the first episode you ever saw of The Office?
Do you remember? I saw it in the beginning. So I learned about The Office, I mean, not to brag or anything, but I was in London doing a bunch of interviews and press for our video game around 2002-ish, maybe 2003. And the two guys that were assigned to take me around all the UK press were from the same area where the UK office was shot. Okay. Okay.
And they're like, you have to watch the show. It defines our work life. It is exactly what happens. And Richard Gervais is amazing. Steven Murchett, like you have to do it. And by the time that I was done with this week-long, whatever, journey in the UK, they gave me
the DVD. Of the UK office. And so I watched that for the rest of the trip and on the way home. Got hooked on it. I went through it was only two seasons, right? Yeah. Yeah. So I went through both seasons. In fact, I was still watching it as the second season was coming out. And the next thing I know, they're like, they're doing the US.
You know, same producers. And Steve Crow and I was like, awesome. So from day one. So you were okay with this US remake? Because a lot of people who absolutely love the British show, they were concerned. They thought maybe is America going to ruin it? But as an American, I appreciated the references a lot more.
Yeah, that's true, right? Yeah. And the UK one, I mean, this one too, but the UK one was pretty raunchy. I mean, definitely. Which I loved. They did not have network standards and practices breathing dumb. They're next, for sure. Good for them.
Yes. We had to blur out and bleep a lot of stuff. We definitely did. It was like a constant conversation. Like when Phyllis gets flashed in the parking lot, I think standards and practices said we could only say penis 13 times in the whole episode. And we blew that in the cold open or something. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, that's the that's the um jackass approach. It's just bombard them. Right away. So that they come back to some place where you probably would have ended up anyway. Right, exactly. Okay, this is kind of a cheesy question but we were curious. What character from the office do you think you're most like? I think I'm an amalgamation of various characters. Okay.
I love food as much as Kevin loves food. I love Stanley's approach to no nonsense. He's over it. He's just riding it out. Like, I feel like I'm kind of doing that. Like, I'm not gonna take any more bullsh**. I'm not gonna do every opportunity. And it's just more like, I'm doing this because I love it. And when it's over, it's over.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Yeah. He's not he's not a go-getter. He's a run out the clock. Running out the clock. I get a little bit of that. You know what I mean? At my age.
I hope that I have a fun approach to life like Jim. So I feel like I'm sort of a cross of all those characters. And no Dwight, no Angela, no Pam. have a fun approach to life like Jim. So I feel like I'm sort of a cross of all those characters. No Dwight, no Angela, no Pam. I'm kidding. Yeah, maybe just Dwight in that I do have a deep-seated nerd in me from when I was a kid. I was a nerdy math kid and skinny kid and didn't fit in,
but I found skateboarding. so it's in there somewhere. Dwight's still trying to get out. Right, right. A big thing on The Office are the pranks between Jim and Dwight. Yes. Is there pranking in the skateboard world? Not really.
No. I mean, just maybe a little bit, but, you know, what we do requires such, such intense focus and physicality. Yeah. You don't really want to mess with that. So I can't think of any amazing pranks. There was one time a guy...
This was a pretty sh-t prank though. It was during a really heated practice session in the 80s and only a very specific core of skateboarders would know what this is. But this one photographer who was known to be just kind of full of hijinks, he went up to the ramp and went to jump in to the practice session. He could skate, but he wasn't a competitor by any means.
And he had blood bags in his knees, in his knee pads. And then he fell and he started writhing around agony and there's just pools of blood coming out of his knees. That's not cool. Who wants that? That was the point. Who wants that? I'm not gonna say, I'm not gonna say.
Also, you know where my mind goes immediately. First of all, like people seriously get injured and then that's like scary part of skateboarding. People were losing it. My dad was actually one of the organizers of this one event because he helped to found, he helped to organize the National Skateboard Association in the 80s, there was no sanctioning bodies of skate events.
My dad was pissed. I bet, I bet. Also, my mind goes to this place, which is sort of like the mom and me of like, now who's gonna clean that up? Cause now everyone can't skate. Cause all that crap is on the- Well, so it's funny you say that.
So that event, I had to come in late cause we were on a different skate trip. So I didn't see it happen. But when I came the next morning, there's just this giant red stain on the ramp. Like, what the hell is that? And they're like, oh my God, you know what? So and so did this.
And then as soon as people started to realize it was fake, he got up and ran away. He better run away. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, people ask us as actors, like if there's a lot of pranking going on on sets. And we especially get that question
because of these pranking storylines. But the answer is I have never been on a set with a major prank. I was pranked once on the set of The Office by John Krasinski in the whole nine years. There was this scene where we're riding up to Shroot Farms in this car and it was really hot out. It was a hot day and we would have to turn off the air
conditioner for sound. And I was so hot and we were dressed for fall. And I was so hot and I was like, oh my God, I'm dying. I was so hot and we were dressed for fall. And I was so hot and I was like, oh my God, I'm dying. I was so hot. Are you hot? And he's like, I'm okay. The whole time he had turned my seat heater on. That's it.
That's my one office prank. So crazy. But if I look cranky in that scene, it's cause I was really hot. Is that when you guys were going to spend the night there? I think it was when we were going there for the bed and breakfast. Right, because Mo's is like running alongside the car. Yes.
Yeah, we didn't do pranks. We took, it's like a serious job and everything's choreographed and you're aware that like time is money and you're like on a schedule. But we did sometimes mess with each other a little bit with improv and dialogue. And mine was when Mo's kidnaps Angela for the wedding, and I'm in the trunk of the car, I said to our director, when they open the car, can she just like really cuss them out? And he was like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was like, I'm not gonna tell the guys, just let them have it. And they opened the trunk and I'm like, what the fuck is your problem? So if you watch that scene, John Krasinski's reaction, he's really like, what the hell? What are you doing? That was real.
That's perfect. I have a technical question for you. Sure. Okay. So we had an office episode that had parkour. Yeah. Have you ever parkour? No. What's the difference?
Anytime I do anything that resembles it, I say parkour. Yeah. Have you ever parkour? No. What's the difference? Exactly. Anything that resembles it, I say parkour. You do? Of course. Yes. Who doesn't? Right. I know. We just did a stunt with a parkour export.
Okay. And he goes by Dom Tomato on social medias. And we, Annie McDonald, who's also a pro skateboarder, he and I do a lot of choreography together. Where one goes over the other person. Yeah, yeah. We did a lot of X games like that. We won a few medals and this guy said,
hey, do you think you could do something with me in the mix? And it was one of the only times where I've been a little trepidatious when I finally got there and I was seeing what we're going to do. Like this could go- All the things you've done, wow. It could go really bad either for him or me. Right. Andy was the one who was going over. So basically what happened was, you know, we're on a half pipe and he's going over me.
I'm grinding along the top and this guy is running from the back of the deck and he jumps through our over under space, which is tight already. And then we have a stunt pad for him at the bottom of the ramp. So he is going the exact opposite direction that anyone should be going in this situation. Meaning that if he hit me, I'm ejecting to the bottom of the ramp. And on his first attempt, his stomach hit my helmet. And that wasn't, didn't inspire confidence. You know? And so we watched it back and I said, look, I'm going to be low as low as I can. You have more room. Get closer to Andy.
Yeah. Be higher. Be a little higher. Yeah. And it worked? It worked. Yeah. Well, you brought up kind of the idea of getting injured and injury is a part of skateboarding. Yes. You've been injured many times. I broke my shoulder two years ago
and my life has never been the same. How do you, how have you healed from so many injuries? Cause I mean, I still can't put my arm, the range of motion and I've done all the things. Like how do you heal? Well, it's not always full healing and we learn to adapt. That's my best answer. You work around your injuries.
Yeah, like, well, I broke my femur three years ago and that was definitely the most traumatic injury that I had and in my 50s, so didn't help the healing process, but I've kind of lost some techniques. They're nuanced. They're ones that are bittersweet for me to lose, but at the same time, I still get to do what I do. I'm still skating in a professional level,
so I just have to accept that. But through the years, yeah, I mean, like, if you see this shoulder, this kind of drops here. I separated the shoulder about 10 years ago, and that's what it is. It still works. I think that because what we do is, we require such intense motion
that we end up kind of getting back there by default. Okay. Do you have like a warmup routine? Like, do you have to- I do now. I used to not. I used to just go in cold Turkey and do all the stuff and I didn't really care.
And then I f***ed around and found out I can't really do that when I'm in this age. So I now I do, I have a warmup routine. I actually do strength training, workout three times a week besides skating. And that's how I'm able to do it at this level at this age. And what about like a cool down? Do you do cold dips or stretches after?
I have one, but it's really hard to get motivated. Uh huh. So she does cold dips. I can't do it. I can't get in there. Rainn Wilson does too. Rainn and I both love our cold dips. Every day? Almost every day. In the morning? No, now I do them at night, but I also do contrast hydrotherapy. So I sit in hot water for three minutes.
And then I sit in cold water for one minute and I go back and forth and I end on cold. And I do them at night before bed because they help me with my hot flashes, all my menopause ladies out there, hot tip, the cold dipping really helps. I tried it and it made me so angry. Like I got in that cold water and I was like,
this is stupid, I don't like this. The thing I don't like about it is you can't move. Cause when you move, you feel it more intensely. It's more cold, yeah. Yeah. So you get in and you're like, okay, I'm stuck in this position. That's it for whatever, three minutes, I don't know,
five minutes. Yeah, I'm not a fan. Oh, I do one minute. Oh, one minute. I just do one minute. Maybe that was my problem. And you go back and forth. That's why I didn't like it that much.
Me too, I don't know. I don't know. No, it's more, and I have been encouraged to do it by many experts, so I should probably get back to it. We have a plunge, so maybe I should be doing that again. Okay, would you do an office quiz with us? Oh, yes, okay. You're saying that like you think we're going to be good at it, but we aren't. I mean, I already got the turntables
wrong. Can I have my daughter on a lifeline? Yes. Yes, you can. I told her, I said, I know you're going to be in this, she's doing finals this week, but I was like, where will you be around noon tomorrow? Yeah. Cause I'm doing, she's like, you're doing office ladies? I said, yeah. And I go, why? I have to call you for a question doing, she's like, you're doing office ladies? I said, yeah. And I go, well, I might have to call you for a question. She's like, okay, I'll try to answer. Okay. But I'm not, only if I'm desperate. She can be your hotline. So, Cassie, our producer, put together this quiz. We don't know the questions. She pulled them without our knowledge. Oh, they're for all of us. They're for all of us. We're going to play each other. We're going head to head. I've already misquoted a quote you knew, so don't be intimidated.
All right. Okay. All right. Are you ready? Yes. Are we going to say, dang or buzz? I guess I can't really call my daughter if we're on the time crunch. Oh, you can put her on speaker.
Or Tony, you can call and have her on with you. Like it could be the two of you against us. Yes, we're fine with that. All right, let's try that. Actually, maybe she'll win. She could be the fourth contestant. Maybe she'll win. If we get her.
Funky Town. She might call back. Okay. Love it. If she calls back, I'll put her on. Okay, perfect. All might call back. Okay. Love it. If she calls back, I'll put her on. Okay. Sounds good.
Perfect. All right. Here we go. Question one. In the Happy Hour episode, what was the name of the book that Michael said he wrote in his head? Oh, God. Ding.
Is it Somehow I Manage? That is correct. Wow. His management book. I didn't know it was from that episode. Somehow I manage? That is correct. Wow. His management book. I didn't know it was from that episode. I was gonna go threat level midnight cause I just feel like that's the default answer
for anything. For anything he's written. I had nothing. In Phyllis's wedding, what color dress did Kelly wear to the wedding? White. White. Ding. Oh, dang it. We did it wrong, Tony.
Yeah, ding. But we, that's a tie. Ding white. Ding white. We both, that's a tie. A point for each of you. Okay, okay. In the Coup episode, what was the fictitious name of Dwight's dentist? Ding, ding.
Cringtest. That is correct. Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! In the threat level midnight episode, who does Golden Face kill in the movie? Ding! Oh, I mean it's Oscar, right? No. Oh!
Oh, nice. Which office character does Golden Face kill? Ding. Tony. Creed? No. That was a distinction. I'll give you a hint.
Oh wait, no, I'll ding. Oh, Toby? Toby, yes, yes. Oh, of course it's Toby. Yes. I just, you know what I remembered is the stunt and that head they had to create. Yes. I was like, I'm in the scene.
Yes. I think I'm in the scene when he kills someone. I'm sitting on the floor with Troy. Of course, if Michael wrote it, Toby dies. Of course. Of course. Of course. That was a no-brainer. Dang it.
OK. All right, here's an easy one. In the Goodbye Michael episode, who went to the airport to say goodbye to Michael? Ding. Ding. Damn. Me.
All right, everyone gets a point. Yay. In the promos episode, who was leaving Andy mean comments under the screen name Texas Poon Tapa? Ding. Nellie. Correct. Oh, I was not going to... I wasn't going to find that. Yeah, no.
That was good, Angie. In the viewing party episode, Erin and Gabe hosted a viewing party for what TV show? Oh, crap. Ding the one with the singing in it. And it's, uh, it's Glee. Oh, ding, no, yeah! Oh my gosh.
You know what? I saw that on one of the episode descriptions yesterday. I just flashed it in my head. Like that was, had I read it more closely, I could have got it. In the work bust episode, who was the hitchhiker Dwight picked up on the side of the road?
Ding, Creed. Ah. All right, this next one, there are three answers. So I'll give you a point for each person. Oh. Oh. In the employee transfer episode, which three employees dressed as the Joker for Halloween? Ding.
Kevin, Creed. Oh, who was the third one? Someone else can ding in. Ding Dwight, yeah, I was gonna say. Ding Dwight, right? Yeah, Dwight. I'll give it to Tony. I get two of them though.
Yes, you do. Angela, you're crushing it. It's almost like you're on the show. In Andy's Auntcha Street, Yes, you do. Angela, you're crushing it. It's almost like you're on the show. In Andy's Aunt's Street, who did Nellie say he was related to? Ding, Michelle Obama. Correct. Final question. In the Survivor Man episode, when did Michael schedule Toby's birthday party? Be seeing. Never? No, he did schedule it.
He did? Yes. On some horrible day in history? No. Here's a hint, Tony. What would be like the worst time to throw a birthday party during the work week? On, I don't know, ding Monday?
Oh, I think you almost had it. Ding Friday night, what? Close, 4.58 PM on Friday. Oh, that's it, okay. I did not remember that at all. Making them stay, yeah. Yes, okay. That was a hard quiz, Cassie.
Okay, how did we do? I think Angela Kinsey might've won. Tony had three points, Jenna had five, and Angela had seven. Wow. Wow. I get a little competitive in board games, Tony. Was that a board game? I don't know what it was.
Any game. Any game. Any game. That's okay. So would my daughter have, so I feel like it, it wouldn't have been fun, but it's okay. Sorry, KK, I tried. If she calls back though, she can be bonus round. So for her birthday, I'm on Cameo, by the way. Oh yeah?
For her birthday, a few years ago, I got every office character on Cameo. So I had this like seven minute happy birthday from, almost, you know, most everyone. We are not on Cameo, but we will do a video for her. I appreciate that. We absolutely will. Yes, we will. And we. And for her birthday is next month.
Any niece or nephew or grandchild in the future. OK, thank you. Yes, I have a grandchild. Yeah, you do. Yeah. Well, you can call that in any time. How old is your grandchild? Eight months. Oh, that's the cutest, most cutie patootie age. He's so funny. Makes like funny faces. Well, yeah. the cutest, most cutie-patootie age of...
He's so funny. Makes like funny faces. Well, yeah. And also when he comes to our house, he knows it's just fun time. Yeah. So as soon as he crosses the threshold, the smile comes on his face and he sees, my wife is Momo and I'm Papa. He sees Momo and Papa and he's like, oh, okay.
他太搞笑了。总是做一些滑稽的表情。嗯，对的。而且当他来到我们家时，他知道这就是玩乐时间。对。所以他一进门，脸上就堆满了笑容，他看到，我妻子是莫莫，我是爸爸。他看到莫莫和爸爸就会觉得，哦，好吧。
It's my time. Party time. Yeah. There's no rules. Oh my gosh. That is so sweet. It's part-time. Yeah, there's no rules. Oh my gosh, that is so sweet. It's so fun. It's so cute. It's so fun. Before we start this section, I just want you to know that Jen and I watched so many videos of you skating.
轮到我了。派对时间。耶。没有规则。哦，我的天哪。这太甜了。是兼职。耶，没有规则。哦，我的天哪，这太甜了。太有趣了。太可爱了。太有趣了。在我们开始这个环节之前，我只想让你知道，詹和我看了很多你滑板的视频。
There are so many, Tony. Oh, well thank you. I mean, so many, Tony. You have been like- Oh, well thank you. I mean, it's just amazing. Your whole life is amazing. I'm just super old, so I've been doing it a long time. No, we're the same age, I think. I think you and I are the same age.
真的有太多了，托尼。哦，谢谢。我是说，太多了，托尼。你一直像——哦，谢谢。我是说，这简直太惊人了。你的一生都太惊人了。我只是年纪很大了，所以我已经干了很久了。不，我觉得我们差不多大。我觉得你和我差不多大。
I'll be 54 in June. We're not the same age. Oh. That's okay. We're close though. You're very close. I'm honored that you think I'm 54. Oh.
我六月份就满 54 岁了。我们可不是一样大。哦。没关系。不过我们年龄很接近。你非常接近。你能觉得我 54 岁，我深感荣幸。哦。
Well, anyway, we're very excited to talk to you about skateboarding, although we're probably the least qualified to ask you these questions. Yes, and I know these are questions that you've probably answered many times, but I think that for our listeners, this might be like very new. So we're excited. Thank you. Sure.
无论如何，我们非常高兴能跟你聊聊滑板，尽管我们可能是最没资格向你提这些问题的人。是的，我知道这些问题你可能已经回答过很多次了，但我觉得对于我们的听众来说，这可能非常新鲜。所以我们很兴奋。谢谢。当然。
So everyone knows you for doing the first 900. This is a trick that took you like seven years to master. Or more? More, yeah, yes, but. But you've also invented over 100 tricks in your career. Do you have a personal favorite that you've ever done or invented? Yeah, you know, I learned how to do an ollie 540,
所以大家都知道你完成了人类历史上的第一个 900 度转体。这个动作你大约花了七年时间才掌握。还是更久？更久，是的，但是。但你在职业生涯中还发明了 100 多个动作。你有没有哪个做过或发明的动作是个人最喜欢的？有的，你知道，我学会了奥利 540 度，
which is basically a one and a half spin in the air without grabbing the board around 1989. And I tried that trick as a joke. I literally did it, was like, haha, look at it, crazy, no handed. And then at some point figured out how to sort of scoop the board using my feet and keep it on during the rotation. And I think that's probably the one that I'm most proud of because
这基本上就是在空中转体一圈半，而且不用手抓板，大约是在 1989 年。我当时开玩笑似的尝试了这个动作。我真的就做了，然后觉得，哈哈，看呐，太疯狂了，居然不用手。然后不知怎么的，我琢磨出如何用双脚去“舀”起滑板，并在旋转过程中让它不掉下来。我想这可能是我最引以为傲的一个动作，因为
I felt like it unlocked a new direction and a new way to keep your board on your feet. It also looks like magic when you do it. It just, I was like, how is it there? The wild part is that there is a whole new generation of skating, of skaters that have figured out how to take that to new heights. And there are literally skaters doing ollie 540s like seven or eight feet above the ramp. I did it right at the top of the ramp because I couldn't figure out
我觉得它开启了一个新的方向，也开辟了一种让滑板贴紧双脚的新方法。你做这个动作的时候看起来就像魔法一样。我当时就想，它是怎么贴在那里的？最疯狂的部分是，现在有一整代新的滑板手，他们已经找到了把这个动作带到新高度的方法。真的有滑手在距离坡道七八英尺的高空做奥利 540 度。我当时只能在坡道的最顶端做，因为我想不出
how to keep my board on my feet any longer. And they've just unlocked this whole new technique that I love that I get to witness it. When you were doing the 900 trick, was there a moment, because you did it, you did so many attempts. Was there a moment? Well, many, many, many before that, yes.
怎么能让滑板在脚上多呆一会儿。而他们已经解锁了这门全新的技术，我很喜欢，也很高兴能亲眼见证这一切。当你完成 900 度那个动作时，有没有那么一个瞬间——因为你尝试了，你尝试了那么多回。有没有那么一个瞬间？好吧，在此之前有过很多很多次，是的。
Many, many, yeah. Was there a moment where you saw it? Was there a moment where it just clicked for you that it made it that one time different than all the other times? There was, but that happened years prior to when I, when I actually figured it out. To the X Games?
很多很多次，对。有没有那么一个瞬间你看到了它？有没有那么一个瞬间，对你来说豁然开朗，觉得这一次和所有其他次都不一样？有的，但那发生在我真正成功的前好几年。是在世界极限运动大赛上吗？
Yeah. There was a moment where I thought, if I really just commit to this, it should work. And this is around 1994, maybe 95. And I committed to a landing, to be honest, the reason that I was committing to landing is because I was running out of time to skate because I had to go pick up my son at preschool.
对。曾有过这样一个瞬间，我想，如果我真的全心投入到这个动作中，它就应该成功。这大概是 1994 年或 95 年的事。说实话，我当时之所以下定决心要稳稳落地，原因其实是我滑板的时间快用完了，因为我得去幼儿园接我儿子。
This is not a joke. Like, you know, my son was going to be the last kid at preschool waiting. So you had to figure it out. So I got to like try to make this stupid trick so I can get out of here and get there on time. And so I just said, okay, this is it. I'm committing to it. And when I, when I went to commit to it, I was leaning too far forward on the landing and I crashed into the bottom of the ramp and broke my rib.
这不是开玩笑。你知道的，我儿子会成为幼儿园里最后一个等待的小朋友。所以你必须搞定它。所以我得努力完成这个蠢动作，好让我能离开这里按时去接他。于是我就想，好吧，就是这样。我豁出去了，一定要把它落稳。当我想稳住落地时，在旋转中途身体前倾得太厉害了，结果我直接撞到了坡道底部，还摔断了肋骨。
Still managed to get my son, you know, with a cracked rib. With a broken rib. Yeah. I mean, this is mid 90s skateboarding. We didn't have a lot of resources or support. And I was just doing this because I loved it. You know, ESPN was not going to show up there. Show up there and be like, hey, he did a 900. They didn't even know what a 900 was. This was sort of the dark days of skateboarding,
带着断了的肋骨，你居然还设法去接了你儿子。带着断了的肋骨。对。我的意思是，这是 90% 年代的滑板运动。我们当时没有太多的资源或支持。我做这个纯粹是因为我热爱。你知道，ESPN 当时可不会出现在那里，出现在那儿然后说，嘿，他完成了一个 900 度。他们甚至都不知道什么是 900 度。这可以说是滑板运动的黑暗时期，
especially of ramp skating. So long story short, in that moment, I thought maybe it doesn't work because I had all the pieces to the puzzle. I envisioned making it and I fell forward and got hurt. So picked up my son, healed up, whatever. And then I kind of put it on the shelf. Tried it, waffled on every once in a while,
尤其是对U池滑板来说。长话短说，在那一刻，我以为这个动作可能行不通，因为我明明已经集齐了所有的拼图碎片。我都想象出成功落地的画面了，结果却向前扑倒受了伤。于是我去接了儿子，伤好之后，诸如此类。然后我就把这事暂时搁置了。偶尔会尝试一下，也曾犹豫不决，
but I could never get my, I could never commit to it again in the way that I did that one day, because I didn't want to break my rib again. Or my collar, I thought my collarbone was broken because it was so high up. Luckily it was just a rib. But so when I was at the X Games
但我再也无法像那天那样全心投入去完成它了，因为我不想再摔断肋骨。或者说我的锁骨，我当时以为锁骨断了，因为疼得太厉害了。好在只是断了肋骨。所以当我在世界极限运动大赛时，
and I was starting to get close, I just thought, you know what, if I'm ever going to get hurt again, it'll be here. It's here. Yeah. I don't mind. I'll take one for the sake of trying to finally get it again. And so when I did try to land it the first time at X Games, I fell forward. It's all there documented, but I didn't get hurt.
而且我感觉已经快要成功了，我当时就想，你知道吗，如果我还要再受伤一次，那就是在这里。就是这里。是的。我不介意。为了最终再次成功，我愿意豁出去一次。所以在极限运动大赛上我第一次尝试落地时，我向前摔倒了。这一切都被记录下来了，但我没有受伤。
And that was the moment that I figured it out. Because I thought, if I can shift my weight, mid-spin more to my back foot, I won't fall forward. And so the next attempt, I shifted my weight to my back foot and then I fell backwards. And it was like, that's the light bulb. That was the epiphany. And I just had to even that out.
那一刻我终于开窍了。因为我想，如果在旋转中途我把重心更多地转移到后脚上，我就不会向前摔倒了。所以在下一次尝试时，我把重心转移到了后脚，然后我就向后摔倒了。那种感觉就像是，灵光一现。这就是顿悟的时刻。我只需要把这个平衡好就行了。
Yeah, and the next one worked. It's really dramatic when you watch it. And the thing that was so moving to me is how the crowd is with you the whole entire time. Yeah, that was wild. I mean, I think I feel... And the other skaters are coming around there, like almost laying hands on you and like banging their boards.
对，下一次就成功了。你看着会觉得非常戏剧性。最让我感动的是，现场观众自始至终都和你站在一起。对，那太疯狂了。我的意思是，我觉得……而且其他滑手都围了过来，几乎是要把手搭在你身上，疯狂地敲击着滑板。
Yeah. But I do feel like that is a slice of what skateboarding is. Skateboarding is this really supportive community, even though it's an individual pursuit, even though we do compete, there's a brethren and there's a kindred spirit of everyone just loves doing it and loves being part of the scene.
对。但我觉得这正是滑板精神的一个缩影。滑板是一个充满支持的社区，尽管这是一项个人的追求，尽管我们也会去竞争，但大家有一种兄弟情谊和心灵相通的精神，每个人都热爱这项运动，都热爱成为这个圈子的一部分。
If you go to a skate park right now, there'll be people of all ages, all races, all genders, just enjoying the space and cheering each other on. So I just feel like that was such a great, and I'm honored that it was me, but whoever it had been, it was a great example of what skateboarding is all about. It was so beautiful. I mean, after you landed it, the other skaters,
如果你现在去滑板公园，会看到各个年龄、各种种族、各种性别的人都在那里，享受着这个空间，彼此加油鼓劲。所以我觉得这是一个绝佳的例子，我很荣幸那个人是我，但无论换作是谁，这都是滑板运动真谛的完美诠释。太美妙了。我是说，在你成功落地之后，其他滑手们，
they like all pile on you like you see players at the World Series piling on each other. And when I watched that video, Angela, I don't know if this popped in your head, but it reminded me of the night that Steve Carell won the Golden Globe for playing Michael Scott. Oh, my gosh. So great. And it was totally unexpected.
他们全都扑到了你身上，就像你在美国职业棒球大联盟世界大赛上看到球员们叠罗汉一样。当我看到那个视频时，安吉拉，我不知道这有没有浮现在你的脑海里，但它让我想起了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔因饰演迈克尔·斯科特而赢得金球奖的那天晚上。哦，天哪。太棒了。而且那完全出乎意料。
We did not think he was going to win. And he won. And when he walked into the party holding that trophy, the whole cast piled onto him. That's so cool. And it was that feeling where it was like, well, I didn't win the Golden Globe. But we did.
我们根本没想到他能获奖。结果他赢了。当他拿着奖杯走进派对时，整个剧组都扑到了他身上。太酷了。那种感觉就像是，好吧，我虽然没有赢得金球奖。但我们赢了。
But we won it because he won it. You would have thought we had emerged. Yes, you won that for, you landed that for the whole community. Yeah. And you, it was so beautiful. It's so true. We weren't even invited to the Golden Globes, the cast.
因为他赢了，所以我们赢了。你会以为我们……是的，你是为了整个社区才落地成功的。对。而且你，那太美妙了。确实如此。我们剧组甚至都没被邀请去金球奖颁奖典礼。
We were in a garage parking lot annex next to the building that they had put a tent over. Wow. And we were with all these suits. Just watching it on TV screens. The suits are very, the business side of the world and they're very sort of like, oh, just sitting there proper. And when we won, or Steve won, we lost it in this garage and we were waiting
我们呆在主建筑旁边的一个车库停车场附属区里，他们在那里搭了个帐篷。哇。我们和这群穿西装的人呆在一起。只能盯着电视屏幕看。那些穿西装的商务人士总是西装革履，显得非常正派地坐在那里。当我们获奖，或者说史蒂夫获奖时，我们在车库里彻底疯狂了，我们在等
for him and he let us all hold it. I hit Phyllis in the face with it by accident in a group photo, but that's exactly what it was like. It felt like you won it for everybody. Oh, for sure. Yeah. And there was just with that trick, there were a few of us that have been trying it for years. And at some point it was like someone just do it already. You know what I mean? It wasn't even like we were in competition with each other. It was just like this has to be done just so we can prove it's possible. And now it's, it's something that young kids do. It's wild. Not many.
他回来，他让所有人都拿着奖杯摸了摸。在拍合照时，我不小心用奖杯砸到了菲yllis的脸，但当时的情景就是那样。感觉就像是你为所有人赢得了这个奖。哦，绝对是的。对。为了那个动作，我们当中有好几个人已经尝试了好多年。到某个时刻，感觉就像是“随便谁快把它完成了吧”。你知道我的意思吗？我们甚至都不是在互相竞争，而只是觉得这个动作必须得完成，好证明它是可能的。而现在，这成了小孩子们都会做的动作。太疯狂了。没多少人。
Not many, but, but it has become a little more standardized. And also the ramps and facilities have gotten bigger. So, and there's resources, there's foam pits, there's all kinds of things that you can do to work up to this. I had to do it the hard knocks. Literally hard knocks. Yeah. I did read that if you create a trick,
没多少人，但是，这个动作已经变得更加规范了。而且坡道和设施也变得越来越大。所以，现在有了各种资源，有了泡沫池，你可以通过各种方式来为这个动作做准备。我当时可全凭硬来。真的是硬碰硬。对。我确实读到过，如果你创造了一个新动作，
you get to name it. Is that true? For the most part, it's a little tricky now because there are so many variations of moves that it's kind of like, look, just cause you did a shove it out of that, you don't get to claim that.
你就可以给它命名。是真的吗？基本上是这样的，现在有点复杂了，因为动作的变体太多了，所以有点像是，听着，仅仅因为你在那个动作里做了一个 shove-it（转板），你可不能把它据为己有。
Doesn't mean it's yours. Yeah. Yeah. But, but yes, but especially back in the day, that's why we have all these absurd names. Right. We were looking up a few. All right, here's a question for you.
这不意味着它是你的。对。对。但是，尤其是过去，这就是为什么我们会有所有这些荒谬的名字。对。我们当时还查了一些。好吧，有个问题要问你。
Is there a skater past or present that you think maybe gets overlooked that deserves to be, have more of their story told or legendary status? Yeah, several for sure. I mean, to offer a deep cut, there was a guy named David Zee when Kevin and I were younger,
有没有哪个过去或现在的滑手，你觉得可能被忽视了，但其实值得更多人去讲述他们的故事或获得传奇地位？是的，绝对有几个。如果要说一个比较冷门的，在我和凯文年轻的时候，有个叫大卫·齐（David Zee）的家伙，
and he was the first person we ever saw truly fly high with ease and with style, even before Christian Osoy. And he was just in the right place at the wrong time. It was just the deadest time of skating. He was a little older, so we had to find a job and just wasn't in the cards. David Zee, it's even hard to find photos of him. But I would say in terms of
他是我们见过的第一个真正能轻松且充满风格地飞得很高的人，甚至比克里斯蒂安·霍索伊还要早。他只是生错了时代，遇到了不对的时间。那是滑板运动最死寂的时期。他稍微大了一点，所以不得不去找工作，结果时运不济。大卫·齐，现在甚至很难找到他的照片。但如果要说对我有影响的人，
my influences, a guy named Eddie Alguera, he was the most innovative skater when I was coming up through the ranks. And people gave him a hard time because they said he didn't have style and he was all about tricks and he's like a robotic and I was young and I didn't have style and I wanted to do tricks. So I watched everything he did. His signature moves were my first advanced moves. That's so cool. So there were a lot of times when skateboarding went away or went out of fashion and it wasn't paying the bills, you kind of went through a lot of these droughts.
有个叫埃迪·阿尔格拉（Eddie Alguera）的家伙，在我逐渐崭露头角时，他是最具创新精神的滑手。人们对他颇有微词，因为他们说他没有风格，只会搞些花招，像个机器人一样。而我当时还年轻，也没有风格，我只想做各种花招。所以我观察了他做的一切。他的招牌动作成了我最早掌握的高级动作。太酷了！所以有很多次，当滑板运动销声匿迹或不再流行时，它赚不到钱，你大概也经历过许多这样的低谷期。
It really reminds me of the lifestyle of an actor where you have a show or you're doing a movie, but then you're gonna have a couple years where you're auditioning, but you can't get hired. You had to find a lot of creative ways to stay in the business. Can you talk a little bit about that? Yeah. Yeah, we had a wave of success in the late 80s,
这真的让我想起了演员的生活方式，你可能有一部剧或者在拍电影，但接下来你会有好几年都在到处试镜，却总是录用不上。为了留在这一行，你不得不寻找很多有创意的办法。能稍微聊聊那段经历吗？可以。可以。我们在 80 年代末迎来过一波成功，
and we were young and naive enough to think that that was never going to end. Mm-hmm. So we were spending as if that was happening. And I had two homes. I had one with these giant ramps set up. And suddenly I found myself with my income kind of dropping by half every month because it was all royalty based and people just weren't buying my skateboards or you know my shoe sponsor was like, oh we gotta cut your salary again. We just cut it last month.
当时的我们既年轻又天真，以为那种好日子永远不会结束。嗯哼。所以我们花钱也大手大脚，就好像这种状态会一直持续下去一样。当时我有两套房子。其中一套里建了巨大的U池坡道。突然之间，我发现自己的收入每个月都在减半，因为所有的收入都基于版税，人们不再买我的滑板了，或者说我的鞋类赞助商说，哦，我们得再削减一次你的薪水。我们上个月才刚削减过啊。
Okay. And so I just did whatever I could to make ends meet. I, at one point I had a really basic editing system which no one had. This is probably 92, 93 ish. So people didn't really have that kind of stuff. So I just was getting odd jobs editing stuff on three quarter tape. Wow. Not even skateboard related? Some not skateboard related, mostly skateboard related. Any company that wanted to do their skate video needed to master it.
好吧。所以为了维持生计，我什么都做。有一次，我拥有了一套非常基础的剪辑系统，当时根本没人有这东西。这大概是 92、93 年左右的事。所以大家其实都没有这种设备。我当时就接一些零活，在四分之三英寸的磁带上剪辑东西。哇。甚至都不是跟滑板相关的？有些跟滑板无关，但大部分还是滑板相关的。任何想制作滑板视频的公司都需要母带制作，
They could do it in my garage. Oh, wow. And I could do it for them. I mean, I got, you know, maybe a hundred bucks to do it or whatever it was, but I got by. And then I started getting hired. Luckily, I had made enough connections in Hollywood that I started getting hired as a consultant on any shoot that was, that had skateboarding in it. Because I was 24 and considered too old to be the featured skateboarder.
他们可以在我的车库里完成。哦，哇。我可以为他们代劳。我的意思是，我做一次大概能赚一百块钱左右，无论多少吧，反正我就是靠这个过日子的。后来我开始接到更多工作。幸运的是，我在好莱坞建立足够多的人脉，以至于任何有滑板场景的片场都会雇我当顾问。因为我当时 24 岁，被认为年纪太大，不适合再当片中的特写滑板手了。
You know, it was more the narrative was, it's for teenagers and whatever. So I would go to a set and explain what is possible in whatever the landscape was. And that worked. It was cool. I mean, I got to be in skating, but it was tricky. Yeah, it was, there were some lean times. I was definitely eating a lot of Taco Bell those days.
你知道的，当时的叙事倾向是滑板只属于青少年云云。所以我会去片场，根据当时的场景解释什么动作是可能的。这种做法挺管用的。挺酷的。至少我还能参与滑板，但那段日子确实挺棘手。是的，那确实是一段清苦的日子。那阵子我绝对吃了不少塔可钟（Taco Bell）。
Yeah, we talk about this a lot too, like even within our careers. Sometimes you just have to like see the pivot and take it. You know? Yeah. Oh, I was going to fight to the death to not get a real job. Yeah.
是的，我们也很常聊到这个，比如在我们的职业生涯中也是如此。有时你不得不看清转折点并抓住它。你知道吗？对。哦，我当时可是要拼死抗争，绝不去找一份真正的工作。对。
I mean, they were real jobs. Yeah, yeah. I'm just talking about like just going nine to five, whatever it was like, I gotta have something else. Right, and something's still in the world of skating. So now you're on a set. It really was just more, whatever allowed me to keep skating.
我的意思是，那些都是正经工作。对，对。我只是指那种朝九晚五的生活，无论做什么，我都觉得我得有别的出路。没错，而且还要留在滑板的世界里。所以现在你是在片场了。其实这真的更像是，只要能让我继续滑板，
I didn't even care about being a pro or being in the magazines or whatever. I just wanted to keep skating. Yeah, I think that's so relatable for us because all we wanna do is create. You know, that's like what makes us happy. Right. And so you just follow that wherever anyone will let you do that.
我根本不在乎自己是不是职业选手，是不是能上杂志封面，什么都不在乎。我只想继续滑板。是的，我觉得这对于我们来说真的非常有共鸣，因为我们满脑子只想进行创作。你知道的，那是唯一能让我们感到快乐的事。没错。所以只要有人让你这么做，你就会义无反顾地追随下去。
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Oh, at one point, I'll tell you how I survived really in those days was rollerblade shows because rollerblading was huge. Yeah. Right. It's the early 90s. Everyone's, you know, just on the street, whatever. And there were a bunch of people that skated Halfpipe. And so they had these rollerblade shows all on the street, whatever. And there were a bunch of people that skated half pipe.
对。对，完全如此。哦，有一次，我跟你讲讲我在那些日子里究竟是怎么活下来的——靠轮滑表演，因为当时轮滑超级火。对。没错。那是 90 年代初。每个人，你知道的，都在街上玩，诸如此类。当时有很多人都在 U 池滑板。所以他们到处都有这种轮滑表演，街头到处都是，诸如此类。当时有很多人在 U 池滑板。
And so they had these roller blade shows all over the place, like Team Rollerblade Live, inline shows at Magic Mountain. And I got to be the special guest skateboarder of these shows. And that paid my bills probably for a whole year. How do you maintain your mental health through those droughts? I think I just focused in on my strengths and realized like living the dream just morphed into
所以他们到处都有这种轮滑表演，比如“轮滑现场队”（Team Rollerblade Live），还有魔术山（Magic Mountain）的轮滑表演。我有幸成了这些表演中的特邀滑板嘉宾。这大概支撑了我一整年的生计。在那些低谷期，你是如何保持心理健康的？我想我当时只是把注意力集中在自己的优势上，意识到“活在梦想中”其实已经演变成
being able to skate. So for instance, the tourists before that we were, we were flying to Europe and we had a, you know, we had a big van and we had these huge crowds. And then it became there's six of us in our delivery van and we're all gonna share one room and we're going to skate whatever ramps they set up in the parking lot for us, but we're still skating. So I had to just keep it in perspective. And yeah, it sucked.
了“能够继续滑板”。所以，举个例子，在那之前我们的巡演是这样的，我们坐飞机去欧洲，有一辆大面包车，现场有巨大的粉丝群体。后来变成了我们六个人挤在一辆货运面包车里，大家要挤同一个房间，而且无论他们在停车场给我们搭了什么破坡道，我们都得在那上面滑，但我们好歹还在滑板。所以我必须保持心态平衡。是的，这确实很糟。
It was hot and I was rolling my ankles left and right. And I'm in charge, like I'm only 25 and I'm in charge. Like, I'm the tour manager of this chaos, you know? But all along, we got to skate. And so that's how I kept my mental health in check. If I was unable to skate, then I would start kind of losing it. I think it's pretty amazing what your game has brought to the skating community as well. So my sons, they don't know how to skateboard, but they love your games.
天气很热，我的脚踝左右开弓地疯狂扭伤。而且我还得负责任，我当时才 25 岁，却得负起全责。你知道的，我是这场混乱的巡演经理。但自始至终，我们都还能滑板。这就是我维持心理健康的方式。如果我滑不了板，我大概就要崩溃了。我觉得你创造的那个游戏对滑板社区的贡献也相当惊人。所以我的儿子们，他们虽然不会玩滑板，但他们太喜欢你的游戏了。
Oh, so cool. They love Tony Hawk Pro Skater. And they were so excited that I was meeting you today. And we meet like really great people all the time. And they're like, oh, yeah, that's cool. And I said your name, they're like, no way. And they were like, are you serious? And I guess you have a big game that's coming out July 11th, like the three and four they told me. So that's- Wow, so they did my own press for me.
哦，太酷了！他们超级喜欢《托尼·霍克职业滑板》（Tony Hawk Pro Skater）。得知我今天要来见你，他们兴奋得不得了。我们平时总能遇到非常了不起的大人物，他们通常会说：“哦，是的，挺酷的。”但当我提到你的名字时，他们的反应是：“不会吧！”然后问：“真的假的？”我听说你有一款大作要在 7 月 11 日发布，好像是 3 代和 4 代，他们是这么告诉我的。所以——哇，他们居然帮我做了宣传。
They did your, they were like, no, there's a new game coming out. They have my talking points. They do. I went and looked up the date. They didn't know the date, but they're like, no, there's a new one coming out. Yeah, hey, just the fact that they know that
他们替你，他们就好像，不，有一款新游戏要推出了。他们甚至掌握了我的宣传要点。他们确实懂。我还特地去查了发售日期。他们虽然不知道具体日期，但他们说，不，有一款新游戏要出了。是的，嘿，光是他们知道这件事，
is a big deal to me. Yeah? Yeah, because we've been working for a while on that, and it's been really hard to contain the secret. So we finally got to reveal it last week. Oh, wow. Yeah, no, they know. I think they follow gamers, you know? Okay.
对我来说就是一件大事。是吗？对，因为我们为那个游戏筹备了一段时间，而且要保守这个秘密真的很难。所以我们上周终于得以公布它了。哦，哇。对啊，他们知道。我觉得他们挺关注游戏玩家的圈子的，你知道的？好吧。
So when things are announced. Yeah, we did an event, a lot of influencers were there. A lot of the bands that are featured in the game were there. A lot of the bands that are featured in the game were there. A lot of the characters that are featured in the game were there. So I'm glad it came across their radar. Yeah. Can you say some of the bands that were there? Sure.
所以一旦有公告发布。是的，我们办了一场活动，很多网红都出席了。游戏中收录的很多乐队也去了。游戏中收录的许多乐队也都在现场。游戏中收录的很多角色也都去了。所以我很高兴它进入了他们的雷达。是的。你能说出几个当时在场的乐队吗？当然。
Urethane is one of the bands. Steve Cavallaro's Pro Skater is actually in that band. The Adolescents, who did songs like Amoeba and Kids of the Black Hole. You've heard them, but you probably don't know what that is. Danny Brown is hip-hop artist from Detroit, and Lupe Fiasco who famously has the kick push song about skateboarding. I just know how much music is a part of the skateboarding culture as well. I was telling you that my very first boyfriend was a skateboarder. Yes. My high school love of my life. And I spent two or three years at skate parks.
Urethane 就是其中一个乐队。史蒂夫·卡瓦拉罗（Steve Cavallaro）的职业滑手其实也在那个乐队里。The Adolescents 乐队，他们创作过《Amoeba》和《Kids of the Black Hole》这样的歌曲。你听过这些歌，但你可能不知道是谁唱的。丹尼·布朗（Danny Brown）是来自底特律的嘻哈艺术家，还有卢佩·菲亚斯科（Lupe Fiasco），他有一首关于滑板的著名歌曲叫《Kick Push》。我深知音乐是滑板文化中不可或缺的一部分。我刚才跟你说过，我的第一任男朋友就是个滑板手。对。我高中时期的挚爱。我在滑板公园里度过了两三年时光。
Oh wow. What city? Watching him skate. St. Louis. I was a skate Betty. I don't know if we're still allowed to call ourselves skate Betty's. That's pretty cool. That's OG. That's right. I wore the t-shirts and dressed in the gear. When you say you wore the t-shirts, what in the gear and you say you wore the t-shirts What does that mean like a thrasher t-shirt? Yeah, like probably in those days, you know, maybe black flag Black flag world industries. I don't remember
哦，哇。哪个城市？看着他滑板。圣路易斯。我当时是个滑板女孩（Skate Betty）。我不知道我们现在还能不能自称滑板女孩。这挺酷的。那是元老级的。没错。我穿着印有标志的T恤，打扮得很地道。当你说是穿着T恤时，打扮得很地道，你说你穿着T恤，这是什么意思？就像Thrasher的T恤吗？对，大概在那个年代，你知道的，也许是黑旗乐队（Black Flag）。黑旗乐队、World Industries（世界工业）。我记不太清了。
Yeah, what years I would have been there. So this, I guess, which I didn't realize, in St. Louis, Missouri, nobody told us there was a skateboarding drought during, like, 88 to 91. Yeah. I mean, we were like, it was in full force, and all these guys would go out there on the halfpipe, and they'd be trying to do the stuff, and... Did you ever go to a halfpipe that was plexiglass? Do you remember? Like it was see-through?
是的，具体是哪几年。所以这大概是，我之前没意识到，在密苏里州的圣路易斯，没有人告诉我们，在 88 到 91 年间，滑板界经历过一次低谷。对。我的意思是，我们当时觉得滑板正处于全盛时期，所有这些家伙都会去U池那里，尝试做出各种动作……你有没有去过那种用有机玻璃做的U池？你还记得吗？就像是透明的那种？
I don't think so. in St. Louis, no. Because there was a half pipe in St. Louis that was portable that I skated many times in those years. Wow, I don't think so. I think I would have remembered that. One of the parks we went to was, I guess, is this called a bowl? Where it's cement.
我不这么觉得。在圣路易斯，绝对没有。因为圣路易斯有一个我那些年滑过很多次的便携式U型池。哇，我不这么觉得。我觉得我应该会记得那个。我们去过的公园之一，我想，这就是所谓的碗池吗？也就是水泥建的那种。
And then there were other like wooden half pipes or quarter pipes or whatever. Yeah, I mean, and it was, I loved those guys. Really creative. Good guys. Just kind of doing their own thing. Yes. And not caring what anyone thinks.
然后还有其他像木制的U型池或四分之一管状池之类的。对，我的意思是，我很喜欢那些家伙。真的很有创意。都是好人。只是有点在过自己的生活。是的。根本不在乎别人怎么想。
No. And it made me want to ask you what part of skateboarding culture do you think has been most misunderstood or misrepresented by the mainstream? I think it's more the misfit aspect in that they want to focus on these are outcasts or that they're troublemakers. And it's like, no, they're just doing their own thing. And they're doing it in a highly creative way. And I feel like skateboarding teaches you so much about how to solve problems, how to be self-motivated and instill self-confidence, like maybe nothing else in your life.
没有。这让我想问你，你觉得滑板文化中哪一部分最容易被主流社会误解或歪曲？我觉得更多的是那种“边缘人”的属性，他们总是想把焦点放在这些人是社会弃儿或是麻烦制造者上。而事实并非如此，他们只是在过自己的生活，而且是用一种极具创意的方式在做这件事。我觉得滑板教会了你很多关于如何解决问题、如何自我驱动以及建立自信的道理，这是生活中其他事情可能无法比拟的。
And it makes you see, it's just this great equalizer, but it's very inclusive. So you just get to hang out with all kinds of different people, but you have the shared interest and an immediate bond. I totally agree. And I think like, I mean, I know that when I brought my skateboarding boyfriend home for the first time with his like blue hair and his like crazy way
而且它让你明白，这真是一个伟大的平衡器，而且非常具有包容性。所以你只需和各种各样的人一起玩，但你们有共同的兴趣和一种即时的羁绊。我完全同意。而且我觉得，我的意思是，我知道当我第一次把那个带着蓝头发、有着疯狂的穿着方式
that he dressed and his like, you know, slouchy clothes and all this stuff, I know that my parents were a little bit like, huh, okay. Okay, cause I was going to like a private Catholic girls school and you know, they were always the mixers with the private boys schools and all that. Like those were the like dances
以及穿着宽松衣服等等的滑板男友带回家时，我知道我的父母当时有点……嗯，好吧。好吧，因为我当时在上一所私立天主教女子学校，你知道，那里总是会和私立男子学校举办联谊活动之类的。那些就是
that you were encouraged to go to. And I was like, I don't know what to tell you guys, but you know, those prep school boys, they got nothing on the skater boys. Like they are, because also the skaters were not slackers or delinquents or any of that. They're disciplined. Yeah, very disciplined. I mean, listen, if you want to date a skater,
鼓励你去参加的舞会。而我当时想：我不知道该对你们说什么，但你知道，那些贵族学校的男生根本比不上滑板男孩。因为他们不仅如此，而且滑水爱好者们也不是懒虫、问题少年或诸如此类的人。他们很有纪律。是的，非常有纪律。我的意思是，听着，如果你想和一个滑板手约会，
be prepared to sit at a skate park for like hours watching them try a trick because- And nursing wounds. Yes. I mean, a couple of broken wrists and things. Not just from falling, but from like a board hitting. I mean, that was how my boyfriend broke his wrist was like his board flipped up and then cranked
就要做好在滑板公园坐上好几个小时看着他们尝试一个动作的准备，因为——还要照顾伤口。是的。我是说，会有几处手腕骨折之类的事情。不仅是因为摔倒，还可能是因为滑板撞击。我是说，我男朋友就是这样骨折的，他的滑板翻起来然后重重地
and then the rest. Oh, wow. Yeah. That's rough. That is, that's literally insult injury. It really is. It really, really is. Yeah. So I just, I think it's a cool thing. And I think that it's really, really cool
砸到了手腕。哦，哇。是的。太惨了。这真的是，可以说是雪上加霜。真的。确实如此。是的。所以我觉得这真的是一件很酷的事情。而且我觉得非常非常酷的是，
that through your foundation, you have the skate park project where you have helped fund something like over 600 skate parks around the world. One in St. Louis actually. And one in St. Louis. That is so cool. Yeah, I got to go to the grand opening of that one.
通过你的基金会，你们成立了“滑板公园项目”（Skate Park Project），帮助资助了全球600多个滑板公园。其中一个其实就在圣路易斯。圣路易斯也有一个。太酷了。对，我有幸去参加了那个公园的落幕剪彩仪式。
It was cool. That's so great. Well, I'm a dinosaur cause I'm gonna just tell you that you that I grew up roller skating. I still roller skate. My roller skates are... Clods? Yes.
很酷。太棒了。好吧，我算是个老古董了，因为我得告诉你，我是玩轮滑长大的。我现在还在玩轮滑。我的轮滑鞋是……双排轮滑鞋（Quad）？是的。
Old school. Clods are cool, man. Yeah. I grew up in Indonesia. So I got my first pair through the Sears catalog. It took six months to get there. But the pair I still skate with, I have three pairs by the front door. I got in Redondo Beach in like 94,
老派风格。双排轮滑鞋太酷了，老兄。是的。我在印度尼西亚长大。所以我通过西尔斯（Sears）邮购目录买到了第一双鞋。花了六个月才运到。但我现在还在穿的那双鞋——我前门放着三双——是我大约94年在雷东多海滩买的，
but they're still my favorite. But there are skate parks that have the smaller like little hills and stuff like that. And we would go and try to do, you know, whatever, just pop back on your back four, jump a little thing, like really small things. But it was such a way to de-stress for me. And it still is.
但它们依然是我的最爱。不过有些滑板公园里有比较小的那些小土坡之类的设施。我们会去尝试做，你知道的，随便什么动作，比如在后四分之一管上倒滑一下，从小东西上跳过去，非常小的动作。但对我来说，这真的是一种很好的减压方式。现在依然如此。
And I have outdoor wheels, those are my favorite. I don't really like indoor skating as much. It's, I like to be outside. Outdoor, they're more like skateboard wheels. Yeah, they're bigger. But I just find it as a way to just sort of check out of my mind and get into my body. I mean, that's why I continue to do it
而且我有户外轮子，那些是我的最爱。我其实不太喜欢室内轮滑。我喜欢在户外。户外轮子更像是滑板轮。对，它们比较大。但我只是觉得这是一种能让我暂时放空大脑、专注于身体的方式。我的意思是，这就是为什么我顶住一切压力、不顾受伤，也要
against all odds and through injuries. Yeah. That's my zen for sure, but I think it's cool. And that's why I continue to do it against all odds and through injuries. That's my zen for sure. But I think it's cool you do quads. They're making a huge comeback. There's quite a faction of young girls that are starting to do quads skating at skateparks these days. Well, I almost brought him in today and my husband was like, no, don't meet Tony on roller
一直坚持下去的原因。是的。那绝对是我的精神绿洲，但我真的觉得你玩双排轮滑鞋很酷。它们现在正卷土重来。如今在滑板公园里，有一大批年轻女孩开始玩双排轮滑了。好吧，我差一点在今天把它带过来，但我的丈夫说：“不，别带着轮滑鞋去见托尼，
skates. That's too dorky. No, I love it. I've got another question. What life skills does skateboarding build that you can't learn in a classroom? Yeah, I think discipline in a way that is much more intense and much more self-projected, where it's not someone telling you,
那样太傻气了。”不，我很喜欢。我还有另一个问题。滑板运动培养了哪些你在课堂上学不到的生活技能？是的，我认为是一种更强烈、更具自我驱动力的纪律性，而不是那种有人在旁边对你说：
you gotta do this, do these reps. It's like, you just gotta get just got to get up and try. You just got to keep trying and getting up and persistence. And I think, I think probably the one thing skating taught me through all my years is to embrace failure because that's how I'm going to learn. And that's how I'm going to figure these other things out. And even like breaking my rib, doing 900, I am glad I did that because that led me to actually figure the whole thing out.
你必须得做这个，做这些动作。而是你需要自己站起来去尝试。你必须不断尝试、不断站起来，这就是坚持不懈。我想，这些年来滑磨练出的最重要的一点，可能就是学会拥抱失败，因为那是我的学习方式，也是我搞懂其他事情的方式。甚至像我做900度转体时摔断了肋骨，我也很高兴自己经历了那次受伤，因为正是它让我最终真正搞懂了整个动作。
Put a stall in my efforts a little bit, but it's more like that. It's that you needed those failures to either learn or to keep yourself in reality. Because not everything's gonna win. Not every show is gonna to be The Office. Well, tell me about it. Or none. No shows are going to be The Office.
虽然它让我的努力稍微停滞了一下，但更重要的是，你需要这些失败来学习，或者让自己保持清醒面对现实。因为不是每件事都能成功。不是每一部剧都能成为《办公室》。好吧，深有体会。或者说，没有。没有哪部剧能成为《办公室》。
I mean, our overnight success was each of us about nine years. Nine years of just out there just doing anything we could. So great. Yeah. Well, this has just been so great. Is there anything you want to ask us, The Office related? Yeah. I mean, what, what is it like to, I just can't think of any other TV shows
我的意思是，我们当年的爆红，是我们每个人大概历经了九年的积累。整整九年都在外面尽自己所能做任何事。太棒了。是的。好吧，这一切真的太棒了。你有什么想问我们的吗，关于《办公室》的？是的。我的意思是，什么，经历这种感觉是什么样的？我简直想不出还有哪部电视剧，
barring say the Simpsons or, you know, something that happened in the seventies or eight, like Cheers, what's it like to have a TV show that's so iconic? It is, it's a meme factory. Yeah. Still. Yeah. I get sent myself.
除了《辛普森一家》或者七八十年代的某些剧，比如《干杯酒吧》（Cheers），拥有一部如此具有标志性的电视剧是什么感觉？它简直就是一个表情包制造厂。是的。到现在还是。是的。我自己都会收到别人发给我的。
All the time. For people. But is it hard for you guys to exist in the real world in that sense? It is not hard for me to exist in the real world. I feel like I have such an identity outside of that job and outside of the fame of that job. And I'm so grateful because I love to travel, that I can go to any kind of like iconic sort of like tourist attraction and I don't get like overly recognized or bothered or anything.
随时随地都有人发。但是，对你们来说，要在这种意义上的现实世界中生活是不是很难？对我来说，在现实世界中生活并不难。我觉得在那份工作之外、在那种名气之外，我有很强的自我认同感。我对此非常感激，因为我喜欢旅行，我可以去任何那种标志性的旅游景点，而不会被过度认出或者遭到打扰什么的。
Like I can go up in the Eiffel Tower. Like I think of like, can Taylor Swift, she can't just go up in the Eiffel Tower, right? Or Jennifer Aniston can't just go up in the Eiffel Tower if she's in Paris. And so I feel so grateful that I can do those things. You can live a relatively normal life. I can. I can. And so I do. Yeah. To me, it's just all like abundant universe kind of stuff, you know? It's just, I look back on it and like, wow, that was so cool. I'm so glad I got to do that.
就像我可以登上埃菲尔铁塔一样。我会想，泰勒·斯威夫特可以吗？她不能就这么登上埃菲尔铁塔，对吧？或者詹妮弗·安妮斯顿如果身在巴黎，也不能就这么登上埃菲尔铁塔。所以我感到非常感激，因为我能做这些事情。你可以过上相对正常的生活。我可以。我可以。所以我确实过着这样的生活。是的。对我来说，这一切就像是宇宙的慷慨馈赠，你知道吗？每当我回首往事，都会觉得：哇，那太酷了。我很高兴我曾经历过这一切。
And then I'm so grateful that I get to continue just working with my best friend. And we journeyed a lot of that together. And that's been a huge amount of support because we started the office and traveled through becoming famous together. So having a core group of people that have known you for a really long time.
然后我也非常感激能够继续和我的最好朋友一起工作。我们一起经历了那段旅程中的很多时光。这提供了巨大的支持，因为我们是一起开始拍摄《办公室》并在成名的过程中共同前行的。所以，能有一群核心的朋友，他们认识你很长时间了……
My best friends in LA are still my friends Michael and Tobias. We were operators at 1-800-Dennis together. Wow. Before, you know, that's what I did. I did that and I did shows at improv theaters and to have that community that has known you that long is so important. And then I just, I like people and I like meeting people that love the office.
我在洛杉矶最好的朋友依然是迈克尔和托比亚斯。我们以前一起在1-800-Dennis热线当话务员。哇。在那之前，你知道的，那就是我做过的事。我做过那个，还参加过即兴喜剧剧场的演出。能拥有一个认识你那么久的社群是非常重要的。然后我只是，我喜欢人，也喜欢结识那些热爱《办公室》的人。
It makes me happy that they're still connecting to it like you and your daughter. Like, that's so cool. I love that. Are you guys ever over it? I don't. I mean, we were doing a podcast based on it, so I guess. No, no. I mean, yeah. I mean, and, you know, sometimes you get like I've seen like snarky comments on my Instagram or something where someone's like, get over it.
看到他们依然能与这部剧产生共鸣，就像你和你的女儿一样，这让我感到很高兴。这太酷了。我很喜欢。你们有没有对它感到厌烦的时候？我没有。我的意思是，我们现在还在做一档基于它的播客，所以我想……没有，没有。我的意思是，是的。而且，你知道，有时你会看到一些我在Instagram上看到的尖刻评论或者别的什么，有人会说：走出来吧，
It was a long time ago. Like you still are talking about this thing. They're projecting their own failures on you. Well, I mean, my feeling is like, oh, I'm sorry, but I kind of did a super cool thing and I'm never getting tired of it. Like, it was awesome. Oh yeah, are you kidding me?
那都是很久以前的事了。怎么还在谈论这档事。其实他们是在把自己的失败投射到你们身上。好吧，我的感觉是：哦，我很抱歉，但我确实做了一件超级酷的事情，而且我永远都不会对它感到厌倦。这真的很棒。哦，是的，你在开玩笑吧？
I'm milking it to the end. Yeah, absolutely. I think that's what smart people do. They find their thing and then they lean the fuck into it as hard as they can. So yeah, I will like yell save Bandit for you for your kid's birthday. Sure, why not?
我会一直消费这个梗到最后。对，绝对的。我觉得聪明人都会这样。他们找到自己的领域，然后狠狠地钻研。所以，对，我愿意为你孩子生日录一句“放过班迪”（Save Bandit）的祝福。当然，为什么不呢？
I'm super proud of it. Yeah. You know, like, why would I get over it, you know? That's like, well, like Kate does the, she does the best cameos. She really does. Yeah. And she did one for my daughter. She actually knew it was from me.
我对此超级骄傲。对。你知道的，我为什么要放下这个呢？这就像——凯特录的小视频总是最好的。她真的很棒。对。她还为我女儿录过一个。她其实知道那是给我的。
We had met once. But the fact that she will say all the stuff and then gut her piano, play the theme song, I'm like, oh, it's so amazing. Yeah. It's exactly what a fan wants. And I like to give that to people. I mean, I didn't grow up in Hollywood.
我们曾经见过一次。但她会说出所有的台词，然后砸掉她的钢琴，弹起主题曲，我就觉得，噢，这太棒了。对。这完全就是粉丝想要看到的。而我喜欢把这些带给人们。我的意思是，我不是在好莱坞长大的。
I didn't grow up in this world. I grew up in St. Louis, Missouri, going to skate parks and, you know, being in the theater club. And oh, my gosh, to have, like, someone from that world that I dreamed about, like, say my name or shake my hand or take a picture with me, just how meaningful that would be. So cool. So I love to, like, my name or shake my hand or take a picture with me, just how meaningful that would be.
我不是在这个世界里长大的。我在密苏里州圣路易斯长大，去滑板公园，你知道的，参加戏剧社。天哪，如果有这样一个我梦想中的世界里的人，说出我的名字，或者跟我握手，或者跟我合影，这会有多大意义。太酷了。所以我喜欢——说出我的名字，或者跟我握手，或者跟我合影，这会有多大意义。
So I love to like give that out anytime I can. That's so amazing. Yeah. That's how I feel like if people come to my Instagram and like price of admission buddy, you're gonna get a lot of the office. How else did you find me? Yeah, exactly.
所以我喜欢随时随地把这些带给别人。太棒了。对。这就是我的感觉，如果人们来到我的Instagram，就像是买门票入场一样，兄弟，你会看到很多《办公室》的内容。你还能怎么找到我？对，没错。
Oh, is it because I love hummingbirds? Is that why you're here? Did you call 1-800-DENIS at some point? Yeah, exactly. I will say that one of my most viral Instagram posts was, I brought it back from when I got to visit the set. I sat at the reception desk and put the phone in my ear. So a few years ago, I put just,
哦，难道是因为我喜欢蜂鸟？这就是你来这里的理由吗？你什么时候拨打过1-800-DENIS吗？对，没错。我要说的是，我最火的Instagram帖子之一，是我从我去片场探班的时候翻出来的。我坐在接待台前，把电话贴在耳朵上。所以几年前，我发了……
Birdhouse Skateboards, this is Tony. Oh, that's so good. I was gonna ask, yes, that's amazing. That went huge. Oh, that's great.. I was going to ask. Yes, that's amazing. That went huge. Oh, that's great. People are like, how the hell? What? Where did you? It was just like, because it's a time warp. Yeah.
“伯德豪斯滑板公司，我是托尼。”哦，太棒了！我正要问，对，这太棒了。那个火遍全网。哦，太棒了。我正要问。对，这太棒了。那个火遍全网。哦，太棒了。人们都在问，这到底是怎么回事？什么？你在哪儿拍的？这就像是穿越时空。对。
Yeah. It totally is. Does the fame ever bother you? No, I, uh, only if it interferes with my family time. If I get stopped and it gets tricky and, you know, if I'm traveling with my kids or whatnot and I feel like they're getting slided. Uncomfortable or something. Yeah.
对，完全是的。名气会困扰你吗？不会，我……只有当它干扰到我的家庭时间时才会。如果我被拦下，情况变得有些棘手，你知道的，如果我和我的孩子们一起旅行什么的，我觉得他们被冷落了。觉得不舒服或者别的什么。对。
Yeah. Or if I feel like it's just taking away from that. But that's rare, honestly. And I mean, I still get to ride my skateboard for a living. I get paid to talk about skateboarding. Like it's just such a dream come true and I can't believe I still get to do it. So I'm super thankful and you know, I don't think I'm some polarizing figure. So people are generally very nice
对。或者如果我觉得它剥夺了那些时光。但说实话，这很少见。而且我的意思是，我依然靠滑板谋生。我靠谈论滑板拿薪水。这简直就像梦想成真，我简直不敢相信自己现在还能做这件事。所以我超级感激，而且你知道的，我不觉得自己是个两极分化的人物。所以人们通常都非常友善
and happy when they see me. And our video game series was a huge hit. So they like to talk about that and I played it. So I speak their language. Yeah, yeah. Are you good at your own video game? Yes, I'm good at playing with myself. That's what it is.
看到我时都很高兴。我们的电子游戏系列大获成功。所以他们喜欢谈论那个，而且我玩过它。所以我说他们的语言。对，对。你擅长玩你自己的电子游戏吗？是的，我很擅长自娱自乐。就是这样。
That was a very Michael Scott thing to say. That's what she said, it really was. Well, should we do our call she questions? Let's do it, let's do it. Okay, here they are. Number one, what was your very first entertainment job? I got to, I was on Captain Kangaroo. You were? How old were you?
这话非常有迈克尔·斯科特的风格。她刚才就是这么说的，确实如此。好吧，我们该做“呼叫她”问答环节了吗？我们开始吧，开始吧。好吧，题目在这里。第一题，你的第一份娱乐工作是什么？我曾参与过，我在《袋鼠上尉》里出现过。真的吗？你当时多大？
I was skateboarding. I was like 11. Oh wow. Did all the ping pong balls drop? No, they shot, I didn't understand how TV worked at the time. So I thought Captain Kangaroo was coming to the skate park and we're going to do this whole thing. This crew came, shot me skating, and they made a little segment about it. Oh, okay.
我在玩滑板。我大概11岁。哦，天哪。所有的乒乓球都掉下来了吗？没有，它们发射了，我当时并不懂电视是怎么运作的。所以我以为袋鼠上尉要来滑板公园，我们要搞这么一出大戏。摄制组来了，拍我滑板，他们做了一个关于这的小片段。哦，好吧。
So you didn't go to the set, but still. I didn't get to go to the set, but I mean, we sat and watched Captain Kangaroo one morning and I was on it. That's wild. That's pretty cool. Number two, do you speak any other languages or play a musical instrument?
所以你没去片场，但也差不多。我没能去片场，不过我的意思是，我们有一天早上坐着看《袋鼠上尉》，而我在里面。这太疯狂了。太酷了。第二题，你会说其他语言或演奏乐器吗？
I speak a little bit of French. I took a couple of years and then I spent about six weeks right after high school in France. So I understand it more than I speak it. Like we were there for the Olympics over the summer. I managed to navigate our family through some tricky security checkpoints, thanks to my French. So I feel like that was worth all the two years of it
我会说一点法语。我学了几年，然后在高中毕业后在法国呆了大约六周。所以我对它的理解多过我说它的能力。比如今年夏天我们在那里看奥运会。多亏了我的法语，我设法带领我们一家人通过了一些棘手安检口。所以我觉得这抵得上学校里那两年的学习了。
in school. And I used to play violin. Do you still play violin? No, my music teacher, when I was 12, he wanted me to do these extracurricular school concerts and stuff on weekends. And that was when I would have to go compete. And I told him, no, I have to,
我以前拉过小提琴。你现在还拉小提琴吗？没有，我12岁时的音乐老师希望我在周末参加这些课外学校音乐会之类的活动。那正是我要去比赛的时候。我告诉他，不行，我得去……
I'm going to compete in the skateboard event. And he said, well, you can't do both. What? You had to pick violin or skateboarding. According to him. That was a real sliding doors moment for you, I guess. It was, for sure. And I said, okay, well, this is way more fun for me.
我要去参加滑板比赛。他说，好吧，你不能两样都做。什么？你必须在小提琴和滑板之间做出选择。听他的意思。这大概是你人生中一个真正的“滑动门”时刻吧。确实是。我说，好吧，这对我来说好玩多了。
And I didn't think I was choosing a future anyway. I was 12, you know what I mean? I know, exactly. I'm not gonna be a concert violinist or I'm not gonna be a pro skateboarder. I just love doing this. And so I chose, and I wish that I hadn't quit. I wish I hadn't really listened to him like that,
而且我当时也没想过是在选择未来。我才12岁，你懂我的意思吗？我懂，没错。我又不会成为音乐会小提琴家，也不会成为职业滑板手。我只是热爱滑板。所以我做了选择，我真希望当时没放弃。我真希望自己没有那样听他的话，
but he was the music teacher and he wasn't gonna let me keep being in his class. Yeah, that's not- Because I wasn't doing the other stuff. I tried to pick it up again and it wasn't like riding a bike. It wasn't. That's interesting. All right. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Firstly, Japan. I got to go there when I was 14 for a TV show called
但他毕竟是音乐老师，而且他不会让我继续留在他的班里。对，那不——因为我没做别的事。我后来试着重新拾起它，但它不像是骑自行车。并不是。这挺有意思的。好吧。你去过哪个地方是绝对热爱的？首先，日本。我14岁时去过那里，是为了一个节目，基本上是
basically Wonder Kids or Amazing Kids. And in my later years, Iceland. Oh, I'm going to Iceland this summer. Iceland's so cool. Oh, I can't wait. Yeah. All right, next one. What do you like to do on the weekends?
“神奇儿童”或“惊奇儿童”。而在我后来的岁月里，是冰岛。哦，我今年夏天要去冰岛。冰岛太酷了。哦，我等不及了。对。好的，下一个。你喜欢在周末做什么？
I like to try to be home and have our kids come home. Yeah. Because they are all pretty much gone. We only have one at home now, my daughter. We have five boys and they all are adults, but they do tend to migrate back home on the weekends. So I like to try to be home in case that happens. I love that. All right. Last one. Favorite midnight snack. That's tricky. Yeah, I don't like it. I like this kind of sweet popcorn.
我喜欢尽量待在家，让我们的孩子们回家。对。因为他们基本上都已经离家了。我们现在家里只有一个了，我女儿。我们有五个男孩，他们都成年了，但他们往往会在周末迁回家里。所以我喜欢尽量待在家以防那种情况发生。我太喜欢了。好的。最后一题。最喜欢的午夜小吃。这挺棘手的。对，我不喜欢那个。我喜欢那种甜爆米花。
Sweet popcorn? Like a kettle corn kind of thing? Yeah, but not too sweet. You know, the boom chicka boom. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That one's pretty good. A sweet and salty kind of thing. Either that or I go crackers, happy cow cheese and salami. You're speaking Angela's language. That's all I ever want. It's mirror and dear to her heart. That's a good one.
甜爆米花？类似于焦糖爆米花那样的东西？对，但又不会太甜。你知道的，Boom Chicka Boom那种。对，对，对。那个挺不错的。一种甜咸结合的东西。要么那样，要么我吃饼干、快乐牛奶酪和萨拉米香肠。你在说安吉拉的语言。那正是我一直想要的。这和她的心贴得很近。这是一个好选择。
That's my favorite snack. A tangent to that question is, if you were standing in line for pretzel day, what's your order? Oh, wow. It would either be cinnamonous sugar or frosted. But I don't care about the sprinkles and I don't care about all the other accoutrements.
那是我的最爱。跟那个问题相关的一个问题是，如果你在排队买椒盐脆饼日的小吃，你的点单是什么？哦，天哪。要么是肉桂糖味的，要么是糖霜的。但我不在乎糖针，我也不在乎所有其他的配料。
Okay. I'm cinnamon sugar. I'm cinnamon sugar. I'm cinnamon sugar. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Yeah, like a cinnamon toast vibe. Yes. Yep, yes.
好吧。我是肉桂糖派。我是肉桂糖派。我是肉桂糖派。对。嗯哼。对，有点肉桂吐司的氛围。是的。没错，是的。
That's it. It's pretty great. Am I gonna walk out the door and there's gonna be a pretzel cart? No, I wish we planned ahead. I wish, damn it! You guys need to figure a budget. Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
就是这样。这相当不错。我走出门会有一辆椒盐脆饼手推车吗？没有，我希望我们提前计划好了。我希望如此，该死！你们需要算一下预算。嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。
Well, we would have asked that question at the beginning if that was the case. Oh, okay. Yeah, exactly. And here it is. Oh, man. Thank you so much for coming in. Yeah, thanks for having me. Yeah, this was so great.
好吧，如果真是那样的话，我们一开始就会问那个问题了。哦，好吧。对，没错。这就是了。哦，天哪。非常感谢你来做客。对，谢谢邀请我。对，这太棒了。
Congratulations to you too. Thank you. Yeah, thanks. All right. Well, that happened, lady. Tony Hawk sat across from us for like an hour. And now we talked to him. I know. And we took pictures. We have the photos to prove it.
也祝贺你。谢谢。是的，谢谢。好了。好吧，这件事发生了，女士。托尼·霍Hawk坐在我们对面大约一个小时。现在我们和他说过话了。我知道。我们还拍了照片。我们有照片为证。
That's right. Thank you so much, Tony, for being on our podcast. And don't forget, everybody, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 & 4 is out July 11th. You gotta grab it. Gotta grab it. And you know what? Tony also has a podcast. It's called Hawk versus Wolf. It's him and Jason Ellis, and it's a great podcast. So we'll put a link to that in our stories too. All right. Thank you so much everyone.
没错。非常感谢托尼参加我们的播客。大家别忘了，《托尼·霍克职业滑板 3 & 4》将于7月11日发售。你们一定要去买。一定要买。你知道吗？托尼也有一个播客。它叫《Hawk versus Wolf》。是他和杰森·埃利斯一起主持的，这是一个很棒的播客。所以我们也会在快拍中附上它的链接。好的。非常感谢大家。
And we will see you next week. See you next week. ["Hawk vs. Wolf"] Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
我们下周见。下周见。[《Hawk vs. Wolf》] 感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey 的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。